salut tout le monde on est des cons
finis on revient pour un épisode
consacré à la g-league it'night vous
savez cette nouvelle équipe qui est
censé développer des jeunes talents et
leur éviter de passer par la case n 6 et
leur faire toucher un salaire
contrairement à m6 et et les développer
pour arriver à la draft nba y en a
quatre qui sont candidats à la draft
2021 on va donc en parler il y en a
notamment deux qui sont attendus dans le
top 10 de cette draft
donc c'est le moment de faire des
scouting report et de voir comment on
peut les projeter ce sera aussi
l'occasion de faire le bilan de cette
équipe jeune de g-league la g-league
igniti mais ce que c'est un bilan
positif évidemment l'avenir le dira mais
on va déjà se projeter et faire le nôtre
bilan à nous de ce qu'on a pu voir même
si évidemment il ya eu très peu de
matches on en reparlera à l'année ben
son prêt envergure nouvel épisode c'est
parti
[Musique]
bonjour messieurs
monsieur berton mes hommages saluent
avec comment ça va vous êtes tous les
deux éliminés de playoffs nba
donc vous êtes frais et dispos pour la
draft c'est ça toutes ces deux en cinq
matches adversité mais ça valait la fois
tant sa lola allez vous avez évité le
slip ou non au moindre accord notre
entraîneur oui mais toujours à l'otan
mais exactement
allons allons revenons à nos moutons
quatre grosses paige allen green
johnattan gaming à isaiah todd vician x
voilà les quatre noms dont on va parler
aujourd'hui nous allons commencer avec
celui qui est projeté le plus haut de
ses 4 cdj allen green qui et qui fait
partie du top 4 consensuel on va dire
avec kyle cunningham avec evans mobley
avec jaden suns du top 4 un peu
consensuel quand on lit tout les
différentes modes grâce tous les
différentes big board alors c'est vous
pouvez allez vous mettre sur notre site
à envergure point ces eaux est allé sur
les fiches de chaque joueur ça vous
permettra à la fois d'avoir les
mensurations et puis d'avoir les points
forts points faibles puisque on a fait
des footings report pour chacun de ces
joueurs donc john green c'est moi qui
m'en suis occupé 19 ans il aura il aura
20 ans il aura 20 ans l'année prochaine
c1 c'est en 2000 2001 m 96 par donc 80
kg je pense que c'est pas tout à fait à
jour il doit peser un petit peu plus
même si il est monté fin comme dirait
romain qu'on salue et voilà un scoreur
un scoreur explosif
un premier pas exceptionnel quelqu'un
qui peut créer pour soi qui est
excellent dans le jeu de transition qui
doit encore apprendre à créer pour les
autres et bien sûr se renforcer
musculairement voilà pour le profil
général pendant que je cherche les stats
que je n'ai pas sous les yeux ben qu'est
ce que tu peux me dire de john green et
du rôle qu'il avait dans cette équipe
de jining belgique en green set est un
athlète phénoménal d'abord et avant tout
c'est un jeune ce jeune homme très qui
sait ce prospect été très en vue
il veut c'était une décision c'est une
des pierres angulaires de la tacc de
l'équipe
angélique portant de balle pour jouer
beaucoup en pick and roll on jouait
beaucoup ont joué beaucoup pour lui dans
le fond bons tireurs pour un tyran
excellent moi ce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est lui justement c'est ça ce sont
premiers pas absolument incroyable sa
capacité à battre son homme de vitesse
pour aller au pagny ce que je sais ce
qui me meut gauche un peu plus ce qui me
dérange le plus avec justement c'est
qu'il est monté de 1 et 2 pour cette
raison le contacter au panier et
l'efficacité à la finition au cercle
c'est un peu plus de succès moi j'aime
beaucoup le joueur
je crois que l'avenir absolument très
très très de très très haut niveau nba
stature 36 minutes les stades brut on
les donne même si on les prend toujours
avec des pincettes
évidemment 20 points sur 36 minutes
puisque en réalité il en jouait 32 il
avait quand même pas mal de temps de jeu
c'est lui qui avait le plus gros temps
de jeu de l'équipe si je ne m'abuse 20
points un peu moins de 5 rebonds 3
passes décisives 1 7 interceptions et
quasiment autant de balles perdues que
deux passes décisives
ça va être important j'imagine pour vous
pour la suite puisqu'il est à 3 balles
perdues par match en revanche 36 5% à 3
points 83 % aux lancers francs 46 % aux
tirs au total
c'est plutôt bien c'est même plutôt très
encourageant pour quelqu'un qui
finalement allan a affronté bas des
joueurs plus forts qu'en nba et qui s'en
est sorti avec une efficacité
ma foi très bonne puisque le tout
shooting le petit s percentage est à
plus de 60% 61 3%
ouais franchement je me rappelle quand
on avait appris qu'il allait en djing
peut-être que certains
on avait peur que ça se ressemble tant
une parodie de basket et que tu chagrine
fresque genuine faisait en cause c'est à
dire qu'ils aient tous les ballons qui
croque un peu là mais cette réputation
la règle elle a toujours un peu de
croqueurs de genre qui équipe qui prend
pas mal de tir et c'était vraiment le
développement qui devait se mettre en
place dans la bulle d-league
c'était un peu sur le reste son jeu
offensif
en fait je réussis l'avait pas ici la
vie tellement adroits et qu'il avait
développé sa palette s'arrêter j'aurais
trouvé ça très bien déjà
il a été adroit et je trouve que sa
palette c'est un peu développé dans le
jeu pour les autres c'est mieux que ce
que les stats ne le démontre selon moi
donc quoi être franchement super super
positif et un jour oui franchement le
dire avec les tirs qui prend est à 36% à
3 points +2 81% à ces fronts à son âge
ça veut dire en terme de forme en termes
de 2,2 geste ça va très très bien et
c'est top
comme ce que j'ai juste mentionné avant
sa saison encore on l'a pas
malheureusement encore trop trop vite
prendre beaucoup de catch and shoot
parce que ben a de facto il avait il y
avait un peu le ballon dans les mains
pour ça faut aller voir le film de timur
et c'est là où en catch up c'est un peu
moi un peu moins bon que le sortie de
rythme et c'est normal parce qu'il
arrive il ya toujours fait plus de
sorties dream dont il ya toujours eu le
ballon entre les mains maintenant est-ce
que jane green
la question c'est est ce que pour vous
c'est l'option numéro un potentiel
d'une bonne équipe rappeler aux fables
sur bad man danané emmené dans trois
quatre cinq voiliers mais il faut bâtir
autour
il faut bâtir autour faux complémenter
s'efforce puis faut pallier à ces
faiblesses c'est un joueur qui va
toujours prendre beaucoup de ces qui va
toujours vous à être au milieu même
s'ils s'améliorent comme passe à votre
toujours à être au milieu de l'action
facilement donc il faut vraiment bâti
autour de lui il faut lui avoir des
joueurs qui jouent près du cercle pour
lui pour aller chercher des rebonds
offensifs il faut des joueurs qui sont
très bons très rap et avec la gâchette
très rapide dans catch and shoot pour le
sortir de problème si la possession
s'écroule il faut bâtir autour de lui le
point joueurs qui ce qui sera rente qui
s'insère très bien dans un effectif déjà
mode typique fonctionne déjà bien et
donc si tu regardes le haut du la
loterie n'a pas encore lu évidemment
alors on enregistre si tu regardes de
les équipes qui ont plus de chance
d'avoir les choix haut du tableau est ce
qu'il ya des équipes que c'est qu'il
mettrait un petit drapeau jaune en tout
cas dire eh ben ça va faire signer
là-bas et use wayne white est un peu
anthony edwards en tous sens
comme tout pas malheureusement les
oiseaux sacramento je suis pas sûr non
plus qui va y avoir une construction
assez solide de la bord pour le
complimenter moi je le verrais très bien
aux côtés de shia ou qu'ici ça c'est
intéressant et je pense à peu à ok si en
plus à côté de shay est à côté de lui
games of america de de prendre des
postes 3 défensivement parce que green
alors
moi ce que j'ai aimé c'est que même si
les fin je trouve qu'il accepte très
bien le contact
il y va et il est capable
parce que aussi là il est très
athlétique qui peut faire il peut
prendre le contact est toujours être en
l'air et du coup comme il est quand même
très gay n'est sur le haut terminé tout
de même au cercle et même défensivement
je trouve qu'il rechigne pas il n'a pas
peur donc ça c'est quand même un point
assez positif alan dans quel dans quel
genre pas dans quel genre de système
précis mais mais mais quelle quelles
sont les situations idéales pas en
termes de roster mais c'est vraiment sur
le terrain dans lequel tu pouvais le
voir évoluer en année un ou deux afin de
le faire progresser et surtout de tirer
la quintessence de ses qualités pour les
gens volent risque super au même si tu
crois pas peut-être pas que ce que tout
peut bien faire il a trop de potentiel
france je pense que le dire aux gens il
a trop de potentiel pour laisser
descendre dans l'adrar oui oui beaucoup
ou pour dire ah oui mais peut-être qu'on
préférait ce mec là franchement
offensivement il a trop trop trop de
potentiel je pense qu'il faut un rôle
assez toujours un c'est toujours un bon
débat c'est le débat que quand il est
rouge vous un peu avec edward en fait en
début d'année eux ils se sont dit au
tout début se sont dit mais en fait
edwards a jamais eu a jamais vraiment
jeu or ball et si on met dans le cinq
avec russell et à andy sera au bol donc
on préfère le faire sortir du banc pour
qu'ils aient le bol résultat ce n'était
pas ce n'est pas tout le temps très très
bien finalement nouveau coach est arrivé
et puis il a décidé de mettre quand même
edwards avec kid avec les meilleurs
joueurs du lot de l'équipe en quelque
sorte
et là ça allait mieux c'est le pari de
diversifier un peu ça paraît que je
pense que green comme tu l'as dit pour
le voir hors pôles il faut le voir
faut pas rêver le lycée il faut pas
regarder la geely faut regarder
thibault et c'est donc c'est vraiment un
petit avant un petit échantillon
je pense qu'il faut une équipe où
il aura le droit de faire des erreurs le
droit de perdre des ballons où il aura
comme l'a dit ben des shooteurs dans les
coins et porteur de balle aujourd'hui
qui jouent des pick and roll il faut la
remettre
ce qui est bien bas 1 soit un pivot qui
est utilisable sur pick and pop est un
pivot qui peut attaquer de francfort le
cercle après la pose du pick and roll et
puis de shooter dans les coins mais
façon et le biais tout le monde d'aller
shooter maintenant donc je pense qu'en
fait il n'y aura pas vraiment de mauvais
augure avant une mauvaise situation pour
faire un mauvais mauvais jeu de mots
cinématographique français mais je suis
pas fan de ce café 12 min sauter avec
édouard au début je pense qu'en fait
green bay s'il arrive à orlando
s'il arrive à houston s'il arrive à ces
parias qui d'autre qui très très haut
dans cette draft yahoo qui ici comme
vous l'aviez ok si c'est un peu
différent parce que chez c'est un rock
star donc ils se disent il sera un peu
en deuxième porteur de balle ce qui peut
être bien aussi parce que mais je pense
qu'il va lui donner de quoi faire des
erreurs de quoi de quoi faire faire ses
gammes
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
trop potentiel athlétique et offensif
pour le laisser descendre dans une rue
où l'on peut déjà s'avancer en disant
qu'il sera parti après le top 5
sauf si bien dépeints médical n'a pas
connaissance pour le moment qui apparaît
pendant le processus pré draft
je vais juste complété avec ce que
j'avais noté dans le scoutisme report au
niveau de bon son son état d'esprit
passionné vraiment par par le basket
depuis très longtemps
c'est quelqu'un qui est bouclée et
énormément suivi depuis depuis plusieurs
plusieurs années et qui est quand même
parvenu à rester dans a confirmé à
chaque fois les attentes qu'on avait en
lui c'est à dire que on en voit beaucoup
inde et des prospects qui a 15 ans sont
attendus comme top dix lycéens et puis
finalement sortant du lycée ils sont
plus que dans le top 50 et puis
finalement ils finissent à peine crow
jane green tout le monde l'attendait
très fort et il est deux
très fort et là on est loin d'avoir
atteint son potentiel et c'est parce que
il adore jouer
il adore jouer et il a envie de
progresser il a un peu l'état d'esprit
j'ai envie d'être le meilleur dans
n'importe quelle équipe pour laquelle je
joue et sur n'importe quel terrain où je
me trouve donc ça c'est intéressant
il ya beaucoup de comparaisons exact
line la ville évidemment sur le profil
c'est très similaire très âgées titre
est un peu égoïste dans son jeu en 4 au
début la carrière une progression il
faut le dire quand même green green à un
niveau deux fois supérieur je passe avec
la grand chose mais vraiment extrêmement
supérieur à celui qui avait la vie n'en
sortant de de ucla puisque c'est la
platine est excisée n'était même pas
titulaire en n 6 et à bord alors là bon
green de toute façon il allait être
titulaire en ait vu le besoin qu'avait
la nba et cette équipe réussit souci est
que ces grosses paires réussissent mais
mais il a il a su montrer que le
méritait ben est ce que c'est a quelque
chose à ajouter sur djallit hongrie non
sinon que j'aime bien le 7 à houston qui
ont absolument tout à reconstruire et
qui pourrait justement à reconstruire
une équipe autour d'un joueur
électrisant qui pourrait mettre des
popotins dans les sièges avec avec kevin
porter junior
on s'entend que keven pas le titre
junior ainsi qu aux problèmes
il va partir jouer en chine bon en tout
cas juste vous je vous le dis par
rapport aux la finition au cercle 70% -
another bien le contact un tu l'as bien
mentionné mais de toute façon quand il
saute
moi je prie levitte super bien les
protecteurs de sérieux défauts parce
qu'il est il a encore pas élastique mais
il n'arriva il est ultra spectaculaire
finition main droite main gauche il
sommes très long sault horizontale c'est
une particularité que j'avais remarqué
chez lui ce qui lui cause terme a-2 bien
éviter ou au cert horizontalement qui
sont très très loin non il est très
efficace très réduit certes est loin du
cerf et à une distance il me dit c'est
pas si mal que ça moi j'y crois dur
comme points ouais moi aussi moi je vous
l'avais combien sur le top 4 pour vous
il est est ce qu'il est dans le même
panier que kyle king non mais les jeux
sens où il est il est dans le deuxième
panier de ta draft dans le deuxième
groupe de joueurs à l'anoci
on va voir est ok donc après évidemment
on va parler comme ça je préviens pour
ce qu ont pas l'habitude on va parler en
terme de groupe de joueurs parce que le
jour de soir de la draft
si on a deux joueurs dont on estime
qu'ils sont dans le même groupe
après on va ça va dépendre un petit peu
de la situation dans laquelle il a tombé
donc moi aussi je pense qu'il est dans
mon deuxième groupe et je suis à deux
doigts de me dire qu'il pressent donc la
dernière il n'aurait été numéro un chez
moi par m ah ouais ouais mon chinois je
maman il aurait été dans le même groupe
que edward ce n'est pas au dessus
je pense qu'il aurait été vraiment dans
le groupe avec la mélo en oeuvre je
pense mais en tout cas déjà laine green
est évidemment prospère à suivre et dont
vous entendrez parler et que vous verrez
énormément puisqu'il va péter d énorme
dunk sur la tête des gens
l'année prochaine qui a fait le scouting
report sur john allen cunningham c'est
mon lancer alan alors je t'en prie jan
je n'attends qu'une vingtaine coming up
déjà ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il est
plus jeune que tous les autres parce que
donc il est né au congo il est arrivé
aux etats-unis pour jouer au basket
quand il avait un peu quand il débutait
son adolescence en quelque sorte quand
il avait 4 ans est recueillie
ouais il débuté son jeu c'est pas comme
si c pas l adolescent sec commence comme
ça comme vous c'est bien de débuter
c'est ça donc il arrive aux saisines a
fait qu'un pas mal d'indicés différents
dans différents états notamment dans les
états de new york et puis ensuite il y
les pas mal d'offres pour être dans la
promotion 2022 donc de lycéens de draft
mais il a réussi à se reclasser et donc
à partir en j league parce qu'au niveau
en termes d'âge pour se présenter à la
draft ça va aller il y avait des oeuvres
de tous les murs programme les duke elle
qui est tous les blue blood ce qui
existe et puis il a dit d'aller angeli
allergy digue était titulaire angeli il
a été blessé malheureusement il a joué
que 13 matchs pour un total de 2 426
minutes donc c'est petit mais au moins
on peut regarder beaucoup de ces 10
minutes quoi on peut aussi le voir un
petit peu en lice cool et c'est un un
ailier c'est un poste 3-4
extrêmement athlétique je trouve c'est
un athlète que je trouve assez rare pour
son poids pour sa taille aussi il fait
un peu plus de 2 m 6 il fait quasiment
100 kg il sert un c'est un vrai
prospects parce que en termes de corps
en dentelle ni en termes de potentiel
sur les ailes une chose rare dans la
lignée très recherchés by on peut se
dire que ce jour là si si si tout marche
bien il peut devenir un genre dominant
sur c'est sur ce postulat ce qui est
plus 20 le bol qu'un jour de minois ou
autre post bnq minga tu me parlais un
peu avant l'émission toi tu as des
doutes
oui j'ai des doutes parce que justement
un chat jouait sur un ailier de minara
nbi il faut que ça shooter et moi le
shoot de jonathan coming up tel qu'il
est pour l'instant j'achète pas du tout
si vous êtes des amateurs de mécanique
de shoot aller voir sa mécanique de deux
lancers francs
aucune aucune gens dedans il n'y pas de
balle rapide
les gens ne sont ré drainerait bien qui
finit de lancer uniquement avec leurs
hôtes son corps je pense que ça s'est
traduit nancy pourcentage aussi cette
année
moi je crois que ça cache une blessure
parce que c'est josé se shoote là est
ridiculement débat lancé joe drake la
main dans le visage aussi longue bloc
ils se bloquent la vue j'achète pas du
tout j'ai rejoint on a parlé avant le
avant le podcast mois le joueur que je
vois quand je regarde gens l'attendent
comme une gamine guardian ce joueur qui
apporte de la valeur une bille et parce
qu'on veut parier sur lui avec un choix
d'olten à l'aller ce que tu achètes ce
shoot
parce que là ça détend un peu la
bourgeoise voilà les stades sur ce
qu'elles sont 24% à trois points sur 65
ans native 62% lancers francs sur 48 ans
a reçu c'est pas bon pour moi ce qui
m'inquiète encore plus c'est que il a
déjà commencé à poster des vidéos où il
met des trois ponts en catch and shoot
pour montrer aux gens qui sait tirer ici
prix que ça pouvait être celle qui
faisait débat dans son processus
pourrait drafté il veut montrer que je
vois ce que tu rappelles que ça ne
prouve rien du tout en jeu il ya des
joueurs de n2 qui met qui met 25 3
points de suite assez facilement mettre
mon calme non moi je n'achète pas senti
je cherchais pas se sentir tout le monde
dit souvent beaucoup de gens disent que
le tir ça s'apprend peut-être plus
facilement que les qualités physiques
les qualités athlétiques et on aime bien
souvent de mentionner les mêmes exemples
il ya l'exemple jimmy butler il ya dix
ans qu ait vraiment l exemple john brawn
je pense que c'est tous ces exemples
viennent masquer beaucoup de joueurs qui
n'ont pas réussi en fait non plus à
démontrer ce tir très bon point pour
tous les jeunes dronne ya les sites and
johnson qui avait été drafté très très
haut avec cette promesse de s'y
développent un tiercé 1 et des dominants
et michael gilchrist et ses compagnons
verra on verra ce que on verra dans
quelques années pour au koropa tuilagi
c'est d'ailleurs ce que c'était un petit
peu 0,37 voilà ce que je pense que je
pense c'est que déjà il faut qu'il sache
tirer parce que non son jeu en fait son
niveau 2 les américains disent qu'à
scalability donc son niveau du type
d'utilité s'il n'a pas le ballon
en fait si c'est pâtir enquête une chose
à être compliqué parce que il fait pas
non plus grand chose d'autre alors je
trouvais qu'elle a pas c'était pas mal
c'était pas mal pour son âge et des
quelques lectures pas pas mal mais pour
l'athlète qu'il ait sa finition en
cercle pour le mans c'est vraiment
problématique chauffe qui l'absorbent
mal les contacts et c'est pas normal
avec ce corps là dedans ce niveau-là
d'être à ce niveau-là
donc je me pose des questions je me pose
des questions parce que alors je pense
que j'aime un débat s'est fait ça en
fait je pense pas qu'ils petit il peut
atteindre son plus gros potentiel peut
reposer que tout le monde le pense et je
pense que son utilité en tant que
troisième quatrième et cinquième
meilleurs joueurs d'une équipe n est pas
ou ce non plus parce que des shooteurs
spécialistes seront meilleurs que lui
dans le fait de jus
tout est donc ça pose vraiment vraiment
question d'une place sur un board parce
que si on ne croit pas tout ça il peut
sortir d'un top 10 si on pense qu'il ya
trop de matières trop de matière
synthétique et puis que le reste de la
loi ce moment elle est pas si folle que
ça je pense qu'il faut le prendre parce
que c'est une bien des plus jeunes
joueurs de la drogue
il ya quand même il ya quand même un
potentiel à gratter ne serait ce que sur
la tête la polyvalence défensive et
lesquels le flash en à pompe il ya aussi
le fait qu' il peut être un initiateur
on n'a pas de parler un peu du handle
mais il a il a un job chorégraphe toile
correcte il j'étais assez agréablement
surpris parce que j'avais regardé gvt
regarder un petit peu de la high school
de lui et c'était un peu fou fou sur
l'une d'elles très haut très souvent en
difficulté sur la main gauche
là franchement j'ai trouvé que ça allait
franchement ça allait seul souci c'est
qu'il a vraiment la tendance tendance et
c'est normal j'ai ça ces jeunes il est
très athlétique a vraiment avoir une
vision tunnel quand il a la balle dire
il pose la balle au sol
il pénètre et après il a du mal en fait
à regarder et à champ à ne pas regarder
ces marques anti dribble ou halo ou
alors à regarder en haut ou à droite ou
à gauche pour faire la passe il l'a fait
sur quelques actions mais il a quand
même toujours tendance alors est-ce que
ça traduit le fait que y'a pas confiance
en son dribble et qu'il a encore besoin
de regarder quand il dribble il n'y a
pas de rythme dans les blés de tête à
tête de face ou est-ce que bah il a
toujours tellement fini avec facilité
projet une panne et que c'est des
actions qui la répéter répéter répéter
est ce que tu as vu d une parle de
progrès ce que tu as pu voir des
interviews ben peut-être est-ce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est quelqu'un qui a
la tête au bon endroit
non je n'ai pas vu - ouais moi j'ai vu
un peu je regarde
j'ai passé mon méconnaissance de
jonathan coming on était juste m'a pincé
qu'un seul jeune homme qui a vécu
beaucoup de choses dans notre réputa
vigne est venu d'afrique qui à peine
quatre ans de toutes ces stars 2017 pour
2010 heure pour n'était là que l'on
parle d'eux qu'ils ne marquent alphonse
lui venaient à réveiller du cameroun
pour jouer au basket aux états unis qui
étaient plus longues ou non ses jeunes
ouailles c'est un jeune qui est un peu
c'est un jeune qui est un peu ce qui
inclut beaucoup de choses en peu de
temps et qui va avoir besoin pour
progresser les choses parce que souvent
on se demande si le report pour
l'instant ce que son qi basket est temps
que le jeu sous la moyenne
je vous aime pas ça trop parler de qi
basket quand je ne joue aussi paul d'un
de match que ce soit parce que l'une des
façons dont j'aime analyser qi basket ça
en regardant joie je vous la même équipe
deux fois ce que je ne crois pas que je
rate un tommy gunn l'occasion fois et
mais je faisais il regarde son homme
avant de faire des copeaux panier ce qui
est un gros ou non j'ai déjà pris sa
sixième année personnellement j'ai eu de
la difficulté avec les ont de la
difficulté à celle qui couvent des
minimes à peine une relation mais ces
religions y compris je trouve qu'ils
sont souvent alors évidemment pour les
premières années ça va poser un problème
pour nous donner du temps de jeu mais
non surévalué facilement je suis très
d'accord mais y ait un arrière de la
moyenne je trouve pour des jeunes de cet
âge je trouve bien des jeux par exemple
prennent prize et à todd qui ont aussi
des problèmes qu'on reparle du temps que
si des problèmes défensifs il côté
lecture côté défense et il est en avance
changées en commandes
il est moyen de l'éthique par exemple
ski ski et ski la différence en g2 parce
qu'ils ont des problèmes chez coming à
ceux qui veulent beaucoup et il est très
volontaire et souvent il prend pas la
bonne
décision josé ya des clauses out qui
fait des fois des clauses et touche un
shooter à trois points à quelques
secondes c'est ma liste et c'est juste
qu'il écrirait il ya cette autre
réfléchir trouver moi je pense qu'il va
ça va ça va se gommer un point au nez au
fond fur et à mesure qu'ils voient pas
son apprentissage mais ça va être
difficile pour lui dans son
développement vers world tour c'est vrai
ça ça va être un problème pour les
premières années même si bon il connaît
la g-league après c'est difficile de
mettre ça c'est juste passé déjà vue de
mettre un choix du top 10 en couveuse en
devenir
ouais c'est clair qu'il va falloir
puisqu'il va partir dans le top 10 ce
serait étonnant qu'ils ne partent pas un
top 10 vu les attributs physiques on en
a déjà parlé à la neige a parlé mais ce
serait quand même très étonnant que
qu'ils en sortent
sauf et là on sort notre notre fameux
point jeunes ou de kiunga qui a eu déjà
des problèmes
c'est quelqu'un sait quelque chose sûre
qu'on nous a dit je sais pas qui nous va
d'ici ses romans ses romans il ya des
yade et il ya des drapeaux jaunes orange
peut être rouge pour certains sur la
fragilité de son genou kg et déjà le
rater des matches à cause de sa maladie
et et benoît oui c'était des soucis de
jeunes donc sans vraiment trop dur
squared mais si on si on s'était blues
me si on ajoute ça plus à plus à ces
risques et ça peut payer
michael porter junior était un choix
risqué même si au niveau il a été pris
ça a été moins mais c'est un choix qui
avait payé
ce choix qui fait encore nuit soit qu'il
met m jonathan kumming à sera a minima
probablement un très bon défenseur nba
oui il a les attributs après entend de
l'église pour le moment c'est en ce
moment c'est le cas mais je crois qu'il
va être un finisseur plus''
éventuellement parce qu'il a les outils
mais c'est juste pour ça moi et pour
l'un pour l'instant bon on a parlé de
ses stades déjà mais mes de presse et
57% certes ce qui pour quelqu'un de sa
taille elles montrent pas très bien
faire mieux que ça il doit vraiment
faire mieux que ça parce qu'en plus il
crée la séparation avait franchement
c'est pour avoir un genre de sac de
style cette presse pour botte t
vis-à-vis sous le prenez pas comme ça il
est impressionnant mais par contre après
ils l'utilisent pas bonne est simple
suffit d'accord avec toi et il ya des
moments où du coup je me suis demandé
puisque on dit que le shoot peu
progressé mais il ya quand même un
moment donné si t'as pas trop de touches
et en a pas trop je me suis je me suis
posé des questions sur son toucher parce
que parfois il ya c'est un joueur très
frustrant parfois il aidé des
compléments c'est toujours incroyable et
puis ils ratèrent quelque chose qui
paraissait assez facile ou alors ils
lecture ou le plus souvent un tir
étrange johnatan kumming on en a dit
beaucoup de mal entre guillemets
n'oubliez pas que ça va probablement
partir dans le top 10 et que l'un pas
encore à 19 ans moi j'ai préféré un
jardin je crois pas du tout vous pouvez
si vous voyez même registre et me
fascine mais mais moi j'y suis j'y suis
pas trop non plus ça va descendre dans
mon big board mais mais pour ceux qui
nous écoutent je veux dire il est pas
nul
l'epa nul et est probablement que de
nombreux joueurs qui ont joué ici et cet
été cette année on n'aurait pas fait
mieux que lui au niveau de gilly
non il est pas nul mais il est pas qui
ils nous voient oui je vois ce que tu
veux dire oui mais en même temps il nous
vend alors de 0,6 ça me paraît beaucoup
mais il nous vend innovant khenin gamme
puissant effectivement ça l'est pas
effectivement ça ne l'est pas ben c'est
ton moment puisque nous allons parler du
troisième larron qui lui pour être pris
au premier tour le déchet knicks on en
parlera plus rapidement mais c'est moins
certain
le troisième larron c'est à zahia todd
donc qui lui aura 20 ans cette année
donc il est de 2001 contrairement aux
deux autres un peu plus vieux de 28 95
kg donc un poste 4-5 et qui qui est pour
le moment un finisseur vais donc moi
c'est un de mes chouchous à ces
atteintes je crois que il a fait un très
mauvais choix d'aller angélique ça
t'arrive parce que celle arrêtée à
michigan
comme si l'état suppôts comme s'ils
étaient supposés life on en parlerait
différemment on leur ait beaucoup plus
haut dans la plupart des big buzz
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est bien mais
qu'un certain c'est qu'il ya peut-être
power up sidewinder jackson mais je sais
quoi faire avec eyes et old il ya une
carte d'affaires qui peut présenter aux
équipes d'albi
bonjour je suis à toi je suis un pick-up
big je peux je peux mettre je peux finir
au cercle je peux mettre des trois
points je défends quand même pas mal
pour mon âge je veux dire c'est le
modèle d'avis bertin d'avesnes bertin à
vis des retraites 3 c'est renaud comme
comparaison m'est arrivé mais c'est ça
n'arrive pas parce qu'il fait des trois
points pivots sais pas il n'ya pas le
choc de david berty en mai mais ils
seraient des trois points il va au
panier date c'est tout ce qu'on lui
demande de faire 72 millions $ pour les
quatre prochaines années
donc il y a moyen je crois aux aviateurs
de saint céré très facilement dans un
alignement qui existe déjà
s'il est capable de tenir la route côté
défensif
ce qui s'est passé at il est incroyable
ballet theater des fois on le voit jouer
sur le terrain parce qu'il hésite
toujours entre deux options
mais si peu d'ici peu juste une partie
des opérations en défensive des pats qui
s'insèrent vraiment très bien dans une
deuxième unité puis c'est un joueur
efficace ce joueur qui va mettre
plusieurs points puis qu'il va aller
chercher des paniers qui compte parce
que ces pauvres ils recourent beaucoup
de pression défensive sur lui piquer sa
joie qui traînent l'ombre si je crois
qu'il l'a 7 les quelques d'envergure
mais moi j'aime beaucoup c'est un joueur
qui sait un jeune homme aussi quitterait
qui vient de milieux très difficile sa
mère ont fait de la prison ne sont pas
et répond dans le portrait puisse un
joueur qui malgré tout tombe en amour
avec le basket puis quitterait
quitterait candide avec ses erreurs il
ya ce faire une séance de ce film avec
avec mike schmid ce qu'il reconnaisse
ses erreurs et je connaissais la bonne
lecture à faire donc ça c'est vraiment
une autre plus pour l'ennemi et moi je
les mois je vais la voir
c'est intéressant ce que tu dis moi
j'avais pas évidemment fait ses
recherches
je me suis dit j'ai rarement vu j'ai
rarement vu un tel trou noir
dire qu'il a fait de la balle il
shootait instantanément parfois j'avais
une pression c'est vrai mais avec
réussite 1 donc c'est le genre de joueur
avec qui tu aimes pas trop jouer mais tu
peux rien lui dire quoi mais il c'est
vrai qu'il a l'air d'avoir une bonne
personnalité en tout cas ça se passait
bien sein de la g-league il a même eu
pas mal de temps de jeu probablement
plus que prévu à l'année qu'est ce que
tu as à nous dire sur à zagato
je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit 'ben
sauf une chose je pense qu'il a bien
fait de parler à michigan
parce qu'en fait à michigan il n'aurait
pas joué parce qu'il y avait à zahia
leavers france wagner et dickinson donc
déjà il est pas titulaire
donc vaut mieux sortir du banc en j
league où il peut jouer des pics et ne
pas pas font avec des chaînes x et
artiller
que joué 15 minutes dans la victoire je
pense qu'il aurait - balmont en fait je
pense que je pense que alors peut-être à
terme d'eads est devenu titulaire d'un
michigan et on aurait environ
en fait il faut pas le voir comme
vraiment un remplaçant dans la g-league
parce qu'il jouait quand même plus de 20
minutes et c'était assez répartis pour
vraiment mettre en avant les quatre en
fait donc en fait même si sortait du
banc puisqu'il a bien été titulaire sûr
que la formule des matches où il définit
ce match mais c'était c'était un deal un
artichaut immédiate l'éthique récemment
c'était un deal que que les quatre
prospère jouerait tous les quatre dans
le clutch pas forcément en même temps
mais mais non je suis d'accord avec tout
ce qu'elle dit ben si je dois de rareté
un type d'intérieur en fin de premier
tour moi je veux qu'il y en ait trois
points donc c'est pour ça que je lai
devant bajeux les devants schengen je
les ai déjà gelé deux alex degroote si
silencieuse ouais je sais me devant m
mais j'admets que c'est un goon est
peut-être aujourd'hui de moi regardez il
ya 1 semaine et qu'il faut que j'aille
voir ce mec parce que 14 fais toi
plaisir ça toi plaisir les magnifiques
donc donc il faut que j'aille voir ça
mais c'est vrai que le bendis qui le
préfèrent par exemple à greg brown asa
jackson en terme de tirs à 3 juste pour
l'aspect tirs à trois-points pick and
pop d'un back up you certainement 56% à
3 points 82 aux lancers francs
cette saison trois tentatives montchamp
pour sa taille et ses traits en mars au
noir oui effectivement 6/10 c'est quoi
ses 2,08 sa commande de 10 duré moins de
dix noms qui peuvent y va jouer je pense
4 à vous alors avec un il déraille pas
en fait il peut tirer
donc il peut rejouer avec tout type de
poste cinq sets c'est déjà super mais
aussi parce que comme il peut tirer il
peut jouir peut être il n'est pas dans
le seul nom shooter de grind donc ça
comme ça il peut jouer avec un plus
grand plus costaud qui pourrait
peut-être bas
protéger le cercle voilà il pourrait
peut-être jouer avec un autre type d'un
terrain d'intérieur quotas il n'est pas
le nom shooter de l'équipe ce qui est
aujourd'hui malheureusement peut-être à
zahia jackson ou donc espoir quand ils
arrivent en innovant nba donc ça c'est
vraiment un argument pour lui aussi dans
son utilisation
ce que j'ai aimé aussi c'est son
utilisation de son corps en défense j'ai
trouvé que même si parfois ils n'étaient
pas évidemment à son âge voilà ils
n'étaient pas forcément dans les
rotations tout à fait au bon moment
je l' ai vu défendre à l'extérieur ben
corrigez moi si je me trompe mais je l'
ai vu défendre à l'extérieur sur des
joueurs plus fini est utilisé en fait il
est large il est pas très lourd du il à
200 210 livres donc ça doit faire 100 kg
il est pas très lourd mais il est il est
quand même monté très large assez large
des pôles je pense qu'il a une bonne
envergure je pense qu'il est assez long
et du coup je le trouve intéressant
défensivement aussi ça va pas être
quelqu'un qui va sauter au plafond mais
voilà je pense que défensivement
j'achète et j'irai même un peu plus loin
tu disais je sais quoi lui faire faire
dès le début
je pense que c'est un joueur que tu
gardes qu'un seul contrat parce qu'après
il coûte trop cher par rapport à ce
qu'il apporte trop peu probable oui et
c'est une équipe de très haut niveau qui
va le payer genre 18 millions c'est ça
alors que la sicile a la chance de
tomber dans une équipe qui joue des
playoffs costaud qui a un peu besoin
d'un intérieur fuyant comme ça et qui
peut gratter des minutes du coup bien
pendant la saison et même un peu je
pense qu'il peut peser assez rapidement
sur des matches importants oui j'ai
l'impression et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est un de mes chouchous
s'attarder wasaï étonne je préfère à
zahia jackson mais c'est une question
d'opinion des chaînes x alors je suis
désolé je pensais qu'on avait je sais
parce que comment j'avais répartit la
fermer mais il n'est pas là deschênes
mx1
est-ce que alan je crois que déjà tu
l'as vu je donc pardon meneur gauche et
si gauche ah non il est remis à gauche
mais droitier il est droitier il est
très costaud pour un meneur on pourrait
même dire qu'il avait un petit baby phat
est peu voire beaucoup de baby phat
pendant pendant la saison avec des bras
pas encore formés et c'est en ce sens
qu'il ya encore jeune on va dire assez
grand pour un meneur oui qu'est-ce que
je peux qu est ce que je peux dire
d'autres qui ne joue qui shoote que très
peu des chaînes knicks c'est quelqu'un
qui est passeur très largement et qui
est pasteur aussi un peu par défaut
parce qu'il n'a pas un super show alan
toi tu l'avais vu jouer au lycée
qu'est-ce que déjà tu veux nous dira
donc il fait 6 files donc effectivement
c'est un 96,17 moi je l'avais vu jouer
contre john green s'était joué parce
qu'enfin knicks vient de là oui c'est
vrai le meilleur joueur de l'histoire du
jazz
c'est ça et donc il était venu faire son
lycée dans le nevada et comme jane green
étape prolifique tréport californie je
les avais vus jouer l'un contre l'autre
il avait commis taille ucla a rappelé
c'était une grosse recrue pour le ciel
est il à l'idée d'aller à aller faire le
magic est ce que les gens voient andre
miller
andre miller en 2021 mais sans le cui
offensif et tout ça malheureusement
plombé par après ce que j'ai trouvé
s'était sévèrement au lycée c'était un
genre dominant parce que voilà il y
avait c'était un buffle quoi par rapport
au genre qu'il affrontait il arrivait à
aller dans son spot là où il voulait il
arrivait à dominer il est il avait une
palette technique pas affreuse non plus
pour un joueur de son âge et donc ils
dominaient quoi il domine physiquement
et tactiquement physiquement pas
réglable de la puissance quand quand
j'allais une green s'est mise sur lui
sur une action il envoya green à un ou
deux mètres sur sur certains sur
certains coups de haute épaules on va
dire mais
moi j'avoue que j'étais un peu déçu un
peu déçu parce que bon faut jamais rien
ça mais en devant un top 15 lycéens a
besoin au gros crus 5 étoiles qui va
comité ucla et en fait j'ai vu je pense
bien plus qu'un joueur qui pourrait être
backup mais ne rien dire mais vous
vraiment il est jeune je suis d'abord le
sait minutes avec la seconde unique donc
ses leaders racing unit avec l'allié des
guides night il jouer sans borne sans
jack se parle de pick and roll avec
quinziato dijoux est pas mal d'action
les poignets qui domine moi c'est quand
on voit qu'ils s'y retrouvent face à un
meneur plus petit qu il la bouillie il a
ils pouvaient aller auxerre il a fait un
bon premier pas ouais il a un bon mais
en fait vrai c'est en fait je trouve il
pâtit de son physique un peu parce qu'on
voit son physique et on se dit aussi
mais c'est pas possible il est
pathétique
il est lent il est gras en plus vraiment
mais c'est vrai il était un peu grave
cependant la goojila et comme je disais
avant l'émission j'ai vu des images de
lui il a perdu du poids à ce qu'il
paraît ou alors il sait même pas qui il
s'est tout simplement musclé ouais c'est
ça je pense que c'est plus ça voilà il
assez musclé il sait il est devenu plus
trace et je pense
d'après la masse musculaire après il
était lourd 224 livres il ya plus de 100
kg en 96 96 moi c'est mon jour c'est met
donc un bon pain bon playmaker un bon
playmaker pour les autres le problème
c'est que sa mécanique de tir moi j'aime
pas trop
donc j'ai un peu de mal à gérer avec ses
joueurs étaient un peu en vous ou alors
je pratique peut-être d'une déception
que j'appelle voulant que des riches je
sais pas encore ah oui parce que 4 sur
23 sur la saison c'est pas fou et 71 %
aux lancers francs alors j'ai pas mal
heureusement j'ai pas rechercher ses
stats au lycée qui sont pas faciles à
trouver
après ça prend du temps je vais pas le
faire comme en émissions qui peuvent
nous donner un aperçu généralement un
peu plus large
par exemple sur deux joueurs peut jouer
et essayer cette année ça ça peut
généralement aider à projeter le tir et
avoir un échantillon
plus représentatif de ce que le joueur
peut faire ben est ce que tu as quelque
chose à dire sur des niches je le trouve
très chaud valin très gentil de l'avoir
comparé moi ce que j'ai vu je n'ai pas
vu au lycée mais ce que j'ai pu voir
g-league le nom qui me venaient
imputable au monde c'est un bon joueur
de picamoles qui pas le plus rapide mais
qui compense avec son moi je retrouvais
son premier pas aussi incroyable que
cela permettra yable mais je trouve que
je crois qu'à la sbee savoir être en
panne sous le nom mais il est grand je
vois moi je trouve je sais pas je pense
qu'il va être utile vraiment je pense
qu'il aura une vraie carrière en nba
parce que parce qu'il est grand il voit
ici si je pourrai calcaire william
schotte papillon michael carter et c'est
beaucoup plus grand enfin pas beaucoup
c'est si je crois mais ouais non mais je
sais pas je sais pas moi j'ai rien vu
qui hurlait joie r'n'b et chez dice
mixte je crois qu'il est ils étaient
dans une fois qu'il était dans le
contexte qui lui donnait beaucoup de
chance et beaucoup de visibilité il ya
rien qui me saute et religieux juste que
celui qu'il a observé le plus parce que
je suis vraiment du genre à isoler quand
je regarde le match de base d'un cours
du karting mais qui m'a sauté aux yeux
la chose à dire quand même c'est que là
il ajouté les deux tiers de ces trois
points
un tiers de ces trois fois pardon ont
sorti deux rives non ça j'imagine mais
sinon moi j'aime bien en fait j'aime
bien le morphotype voilà moi c'est
j'aime bien les meneurs de cette
taille-là 30 15 16 un peu costaud j'ai
souvent on aime but on se rend compte
que les joueurs qui paraissait un peu
grave ils ont des petits trucs cachés
justement sous la couche de sous la
couche de graisse saluant plouasne sa
regrettée chronique des trois secondes
dans le raclette mais ça ça mais ouais
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un potentiel
quelque part mais j'ai du mal à trouver
des arguments pour l'expliquer mais là
sur la vidéo que j'ai vu je ne le
reconnaît pas son corps et ouais ouais
franchement il est très vite il a
dessiné les muscles il a il s'est tracée
mais ça va vite c'est à cet âge là
directement
donc ça reste quand même positif oui bah
ça veut dire c'est mieux que quelqu'un
qui repart beau c'est quoi ça veut dire
qu'il travaillait et chez pas le fait de
venir de l'alaska salle auront un peu
sympathique
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il est forte
parce qu'il a joué au basket comme des
ours polaires
en tout cas je sais plus douce mais de
faire banques
trois amis à venir fairbanks piaggio
noise verwee il et il est prêt sous les
mêmes latitudes tutoie ben oui mais
voilà des chenilles que c'était le
quatrième larron pour finir messieurs
est ce que vous avez un avis sur cette
première année de geely il ya eu le
recrutement là pour la deuxième année
donc on a deux joueurs top 10 deux
recrues top 10 qui sort du lycée qui
vont geely qui sont hardy et michael
foster et michael foster merci et
scooters anderson qui va faire deux ans
voilà scooter anderson qui va faire deux
ans donc va gagner son millions ça oui
ea tg être des jeunes vérifier aussi un
chinois parce qu'il faut être précis
oui un chinois qui dans l'année en lien
mais ça y avait un indien philippe en
galice auto ya pas trop jouer qui va
jouer une bielle et là il ya un chinois
qui a des comités de gonzague a pour
aller en djaoui j'ai besoin pour être
totalement pression alors pour eux je
sais pas vraiment à quoi ça sert pour
green et kunming a on est sûr que
c'était positif messieurs il
il ya il existe des discours qui disent
va envoyer vue koenig à mes mots blé en
fait ça se trouve ils auraient zéro eu
la même cote peut être mieux en jouant
ici c'est une drôle c'est sur cette
drôle d'expérience parce que c'était une
première mais la pilule à la pandémie
ben là et ça avait l'air parfois un peu
d'une solution du genre ah tiens voici
notre place
ou est ce qu est ce qu on met les
prospects sur l'étagère de lundi mais
d'année en année je crois que le
programme va s'améliorer on va voir s'il
est chez les joueurs ont du succès en
nba
on veut voir de plusieurs jours à
considérer cette option le plus
rapidement puis plus souvent donc moi je
sais que c'est quand même une réussite
est-ce que juge de paix c'est la draft
où c'est la carrière et demi pour la
dignité
je crois qu'on est une bonne question je
comprends que c'est la brave parce que
c'est un peu touche les intéressent les
jeunes et les jeunes jouent alors d'être
actif plus haut possible d'avoir le plus
d'argent
avoir de l'argent en garantie au revoir
mais pour l'instant moi je crie je
dirais que cela le halage est ce que le
finalement le parce que green ekunha ça
va peut-être pas changer grand chose est
ce que finalement les cas de nix et todd
vont pas être décisif dans le choix de
plusieurs prospects dans les années à
venir en disant si je suis que le
troisième meilleur prospect geely va y
aller
si les deux sont choisis au premier tour
au contraire et se dire on va finalement
c'est quand même l'assurance d'être
franchement s'ils font quatre sur quatre
oui là ça va ça va vraiment mettre ça en
avant
je pense que tu l'as dit pour qui mme
inga pour green pour les méga star
lycéenne faut quand même être prêt à
pouvoir jouer en ligue 1
guten morgen la critiquer mais
physiquement il était prêt à jouer
contre des arguments contrairement à d
brandon boston
they will i am ce qu'on a vu à m6 etc
c'est vrai c'est tout frais c'est vrai
on aura sûrement l'expérience de voir et
money bates qui lui a peut-être pas le
corps pour mais il va y aller mais a
clairement dit l'icg
donc ça pourrait être intéressant c'est
pour être top à prospect présentation de
grand chose pour nick stone a pour moi
tonnes je pense que oui c'était un bon
choix
j'ai lu pas mal de jus de deux scouts
qui étaient un peu sceptiques qui
disaient qu'ils progressaient pas trop
lissé et que bassila léa michigan avec
john howard
là pas sûr qu'il est vraiment trop temps
de jeu vous pouvez c'est pas mal pour
des films x
si l'on était le meneur titulaire de
ucla devant tyler campbell oui c'est sûr
je suis pas sûr ben qu'il aurait été de
vente ailleurs comme george karl wolf
est un mètre soixante six mois je sais
mais je chromique creux et même beaucoup
de tailleur campbell donc
ou alors il aurait joué 20 minutes 25
minutes il aurait pu jouer tous les deux
ceci dit avec en plus ce racket jo zheng
et bernard bien sûr bref c'est qu'aussi
kazan 5 alex déjardin qui veut juste
voir le monde brûlé mais je pense que je
suis qui a pris le plus de risques ce
qui pourrait peut-être de plus en pâtir
ses knicks mais en même temps est-ce que
c'est pas le moment dont des quatre
autorise seulement
oui peut-être tous les avis divergent
donc je pense que lorsque moi moi je
fasse et je pense que dans ce discours
il ya beaucoup de tout blanc ou tout
noir
ceux qui détestaient ce qui était un peu
féru de 1,6 étant maintenant on n'aime
pas
qu'ils aillent prendre leur argent et
tout ce qui est adore notes d'été
détester l'ancien était en mode c'est
général ça va tout changer je pense que
mettre un peu la chance finalement assez
peu de choses ça change assez peu de
choses c'est mais c'est une opportunité
différentes pour des pour des joueurs de
se montrer sa connu un certain succès
enjoy de mardi il est une énorme recrue
scooter anderson aussi michael foster je
connais moins bien il est dans beaucoup
beaucoup de classement et puis si ça se
passe bien et qu'ils arrivent à faire et
money bates et où diane dufresne et
d'autres superstars comme ça de 15 16
ans le programme ce sera un peu plus
pérenniser je pense en tout cas
green kumming à je pense ont participé à
une certaine forme de pérennisation de
la chose ne sont pas viande est alors
c'était une bulle g-league en plein
milieu d'une saison il y avait vraiment
de quoi avoir peur
je trouve et en fait non ils sont elles
beaucoup disaient ce qu'ils vont gagner
un match dans l'argent que ça se fasse
ils ont commencé par six victoires en
neuf matchs du roi avant de s'effondrer
un peu donc ça a été saisie moi je suis
un fait assez satisfait le puis ça ça
permet de parler d'un peu de tout ça la
formation il ya la ligue overtime qui se
met en place
c'est pas de diar johnson qui
considérait la g-league aussi mouillé
par ces machines non dieu ordonne il a
des communes de syracuse et il considère
beaucoup d'aller avec la g-league en
même temps qu'eux
scooter anderson et et money bates que
je vais vivre avec cela rime-t-il
incroyable prénom évidemment on salue
tous les coffee shops burns inc
pour le point sur les comparaisons
annecy et geely nba l' europe
il ya un très bon article qui existent
de vie athlétique pour ceux qui sont
abonnés ou notamment une interview
jarrett jack qui dit bah moi j'avais
beaucoup d'à priori mais je trouve que
les conditions dans lesquelles ils sont
mises sont exceptionnels y compris au
niveau de l'éducation les arts sont
adaptés aux athlètes etc
il dit les conditions sont
exceptionnelles mais il dit en même
temps moi j'échangerais mes années
collège pour vernon c'est vraiment très
intéressant
ou alors c'est un entraînement à walnut
creek là c'est incroyable
chartis jarrett jack qui va peut-être
encore encadrer les jeunes de la
g-league in night puisqu'on la panique
cela john jack et warrior l'année
prochaine puisqu'on rappelle qu'ils sont
encadrés par des vétérans un peu comme
en nba mais des vétérans peut-être un
peu plus fort que dans l'allier seigner
ça c'était mon petit tacle gratuit pour
mettre encore taper le longue ccim de
visionnage nba
merci à l'âne merci ben tiens toi merci
à toi seule fin
un mois et demi un mois et demi avant la
draft
évidemment on se retrouve très bientôt
on joue gros dirige vers notre site mais
on est peut-être lourd mais là y'a du y
est contenu exceptionnel il ya cinquante
soutine report bouge pas au moins une
vingtaine de lignes 20 25 lignes chacun
voire plus c'est très complet les points
forts les points faibles les stats les
mensurations les photos les noms les
deuxièmes non way to ya tout il ya tous
nos podcasts qui sont taillé tout le
stock pour ce grain et à nos vidéos
notre dernière vidéo interview d'un
prospect qui pourrait être drafté on se
sera fait mais promis il ya des photos
de brent bloomberg pour nos vidéos
allez vous abonner également à notre
chaîne youtube merci beaucoup et à tous
et on vous dis à très bientôt fait des
bisous jeun
[Musique]